their number one agenda was to rough us
up the killing of george floyd
sparked a global movement of
demonstrations
in the united states some peaceful
protests ended
in violent clashes with police you look
like you want to kill
some american police have been widely
condemned for using excessive force
during demonstrations
in particular rubber bullets and tear
gas
sky news has carried out a joint
investigation with the guardian
bellingcat and lighthouse reports and we
can now reveal
that many of these officers are also
using uk-made
anti-riot gear in some cases in clashes
against protesters
passers-by and journalists british
equipment has been used in the united
states in a way which is
contrary to the law and has been used
for internal oppression the uk
government claims
there is no evidence of this but we're
gonna show you
what equipment is being used who it's
being used against
and why this matters
[Music]
our investigation centers around shields
like this one they are scorpion solo
shields
made by british company called dms
plastics which specializes in personal
protection equipment
we should make clear from the outset
there is no suggestion of
any wrongdoing by this company they
simply manufactured the shields
which were legally sold to a distributor
in the us
the shields around with a white logo
showing the scorpion brand
and distinctive arm straps and bolts
and they are being used widely by
security services
across the united states this picture
shows members of the us secret service
using the scorpion solo shields
on the 1st of june 2020
here we flip the picture and zoomed in
the distinctive scorpion logo is clearly
visible
and they're advancing again the next
clip we're going to show you
is from that same day tim myers a
cameraman for australian channel
7 news was smashed in the stomach by an
officer
with a shield if you rewind the clip
and zoom in here we can see again that
distinctive
scorpion logo and the telltale bolts
the the cameraman doesn't appear and
neither does the does his journalist
with him
don't appear to form any threat towards
him um
and over here we would say a better
option would have been just to say
can you move rather than come forward
and then strike him with the shield two
officers were placed
on administrative duties pending an
investigation after this incident
a bbc cameraman was charged at by what
appears to be a u.s
parks police officer
again if we slow this down and pause it
here
you can see that white logo and it isn't
the only example
of questionable police behavior only
time they communicated is when you
they started throwing the flash grenades
and a tear gas
and then at that point all they were
saying was move in a very aggressive way
with the batons and the shields so it
was complete silence
until the minute they decide to attack
us
kishon mcdonald was at the june the
first protests in washington dc
he was pushed back with one of the
scorpion shields by me standing here
kind of just recording they felt as
though i wasn't obeying
so they took a shield and they they
moved me and i had my phone they kept
just moving it back
and that's when you had about 15 20 cop
just have a line they kind of locked
arms and they just ran
forward and that's when the shields kind
of just pushed us back
i'm kind of younger and i'm kind of
athletic so i was able to kind of stay
on my feet
but you had about five or six people
fail it's a piece of
protective equipment and for the most
part
officers will use it to defend themself
from things being thrown at them
now if someone comes up to the officer
and
tries to grab the shield potentially the
officer can use
a push away tactic to distance the
person if they're coming at them
with a weapon of some sort they might
use the edge of the shield to distance
that person
so it very depends very much on the
circumstance the officer is
faced with at the time they were
physically hitting people with the
shields
i mean they was using them like a
baton swipe sweeping left to right
going back from their bodies forward
just
all in the chance to get us pushed back
when
we had enough communication enough
space where they could have just told us
simply so that's where
the chaos and the safety was disregarded
because
i didn't see it was totally unnecessary
totally ridiculous to do it
so we've proven that uk-made shields are
not only used by police officers
who have been investigated for improper
force
but also that they are used in
confrontations
against protesters and journalists
so why is this happening with uk made
equipment
not allowed to sell right equipment
if it is being used for internal
repression so then the question is
what's internal repression
well internal repression is unlawfully
hitting people
it is attacking members of the press it
is using
unlawful violence it is using it in
order to
suppress a legitimate lawful
demonstrations
it doesn't matter what country you come
from you know the british have decided
not to sell any more of this stuff
to hong kong and to belarus but the law
is the law and it applies to everybody
equally
and so it has to apply to the united
states as well the uk government held a
review of the exports of anti-riot gear
the united states as part of a decision
whether to continue to allow sales of
equipment to them
it found that there was no clear risk
that the items might be used for
internal repression
the government also stated that the
united states is
a beacon for freedom opportunity
and democracy as a result the decision
was made
to continue with the sales although the
government has admitted it's
possible british-made kit could have
been used in the protests
it says there is no evidence of it it
says
it used the resources of both the
foreign office and the department for
trade
to search for evidence it found no
british kit
but say it assumes it could have been
present
but we can show it was used by at least
six
different law enforcement agencies
across three different u.s states
in atlanta these police officers
arrested a lone woman
after dragging her to the ground
everybody
if we pause the video here you can see
their fellow officer
standing next to them and when we zoom
in you can see a scorpion shield
here is another example for you in salt
lake city
this officer shot at protesters from
close range
if we rewind and zoom in
once again you can see a scorpion shield
uk should not be selling rubber bullets
tear gas or any other
kind of crowd control equipment which is
being used in that way
because the end result doesn't just have
a terrible impact on people in the u.s
it also reflects
very badly on the uk as well the uk
should not be complicit in police abuse
sky news began looking at uk anti-riot
kit
as part of an investigation team with
members of the guardian bellingcat
and lighthouse reports we identified
these shields
through a list of suppliers to the us
compiled by the activist group
campaign against the arms trade we cross
referenced their distinctive shields
with pictures and videos
and found a huge number of examples of
the shield being used
including by officers who were then
investigated
over their handling there were even
pictures
of the u.s president donald trump
standing next to police holding them
we are supposed to have arms control
mechanisms in this country
the one thing that we don't have is any
control and that is really worrying
and that has to change we really need
to apply the law properly and yes of
course
we can sell armaments we can sell right
right equipment
around the world so long as it's done
fairly and as long as it's done properly
and so long as it's in accordance with
the law
but frankly from what we have seen the
way in which law enforcement has been
used
in the united states recently stuff made
in britain should not be used for those
purposes
and that's that
[Music]
you